[Music]
and Darwinism news Darwin submitted by
supermarket sweep that was a great show
I love that show I love this what's that
show about Oh wouldn't a race and try to
put up the car I thought that was a
dopest [ __ ] and then they ended up doing
it for kids I think on Nickelodeon were
they going to a toy store I want to do
that so bad
I've always wanted to do that an uber
driver was charged with manslaughter
Jesus after allowing a teen to car surf
on his roof oh it's quite different than
supermarket sweep
man yeah yeah why that's sad for the
gram dude for the tubes so he's like
yeah you can car surf up man in high
school I knew his dude that was car
surfing and he flew off and that [ __ ]
was hilarious well and the hilarious
part was wasn't even that he flew off it
was how dramatic they were about him
flying off like his do Walker I remember
because I actually picked him up off the
road and I put him on the side of the
road and I guess he was friends with the
other dude and the guy like looked it
and he'd grab the hands like this is it
April just get out of here man get her
before the Costco he actually listened
to him I don't want you to cut just get
out you're my bro man just just get out
of here like zombies are coming in he's
like I'm taking it for the team dude the
cops gone can you just get out of Anila
Road oh my god I could on his leg and I
was about it when you car surf you're
supposed to do it without hitting the
gas you just let the brakes go I think
they didn't get that note although this
[ __ ] was crazy this was like they sped
and swerved Makai sure yeah that's like
goes right in the whip oh yeah
but that's super slow though you just
let it go
from you of all people in this room I
don't think I know ghost ride the whip
no I didn't I am a promulgator of that
movement I would say remember the keiki
challenge like everybody be [ __ ]
crashing I love the [ __ ] famous my
favorite one it's still some of my
favorite videos ever our ghost ride the
whip fail videos where people got run
over by the car isn't [ __ ] cuz they were
like it's a ghost ride through it and
then the car would run them over from
the back anyway oh [ __ ] like the back
would get run over they actually do
ghost ride the wave because they're a
ghost town yeah it's perfect I like the
ones when they're going downhill and in
the car it starts to go really fast and
then they chase the car down
it just gets right it that goes from
being such a happy thing to like oh no
no my cars out of control like it's
great yeah so this this story here this
takes place in New York and his driver
24 year old named Daniel he was charged
with second degree manslaughter
because what happened here was there are
these three teenagers they were drinking
they decided to get an uber to get home
and when they were in the uber they were
they pretty much convinced this driver
because they offered him $70 cash and
then gave him $40 if they would let him
let them climb onto the cars roof at an
intersection so then they could car sir
all three gold took off so there were
two guys on the roof oh dude one guy was
recording the other kid was recording
for snapchat and then she beat him
record and didn't happen so then that's
when this fifteen-year-old kid named
Ryan he fell off the 2010 toyota
highlander and what's a pretty talk or
two yeah he hit his head and so he said
think it was fine he's just like no no
I'm okay I'm okay or whatever you they
went home got a Kardashian he knocked
out of me
oh he died in his sleep oh my god
because he didn't think nothing was
wrong you're not supposed to sleep when
you have a concussion oh my god geez bud
even know he had a concussion
he was drunk - yeah well he's a teenager
he was drunk
yeah dude and your last moment that your
parents can see is you [ __ ] surfing
on car surfing on a shady burr why did
he have facetune on his face okay they
do a lot of that I don't know what he
got punched in the face manslaughter
right that's what he's in yeah yeah dude
because I wouldn't probably got peer
pressured into doing that if I was the
uber driver and they wouldn't even have
to pay me
yeah just peer pressure along cuz
they're kids and they're cooler than you
so you're like man I wanna be cool yeah
I'm cool like this reminds me of the
days when I wanted to be like the cool
high school kids if you say no then
you're an old guy yeah he's only 24 well
what right but these kids are like you
know 15 they're like the cool way cool I
would have called the cops on the
children and I would have the cops take
them home by sensible David you know
what I would have been more right I
would have said officer these kids are
debrie ated where are their parents this
has been another segment with sensible
David thank you I think I would have
been a lot more safer and I said that's
let's go to the Walmart parking lot
concrete the same concrete that they use
on the road let's go to the football
field okay what is it I thought he was
done no no you go to the Walmart parking
lot but I also wouldn't accelerate like
this guy is that the intersection in
Danny's [ __ ] hitting the gas he
obviously never done car surfing me
maybe it was still at a stop and because
they're drunk they fell off on their own
that's true
help my kids aren't gonna be this
dumb dude you're this dumb no I never do
[ __ ] like this one are you risky do you
have risky behavior or do you just yeah
he doesn't tie his shoes and he breaks
ball today that's amazing I think David
lives a normal life and then life [ __ ]
him in the butt I don't think he is in
bed shake you David doesn't do stupid
[ __ ] think his kid is gonna not inherit
that bad luck well if his kid does this
behavior with his luck is double [ __ ]
his kid will get a concussion riding in
the front seat of a Highlander just
relaxing exactly with the seatbelt off
yeah dude Joe Joe will put a speed spin
speed stick deodorant on the bottom of
his foot and he'll walk on a wooden
floor and everyone's like oh and he just
walks there he gets something from her
fridge he walks back nothing happens to
David steps off a curb and breaks his
leg very true yep I actually do
dangerous [ __ ] and nothing happens to me
up consider that's particleboard dude it
has it has some sort of work we would
it's okay all right
yeah there's actual wood this this is
wood - yeah
this is bamboo but it's still wood
yeah oh this is some kind of wood this
part is we don't know yeah see if we get
a more wood can we get more whatever
here yeah knock on your dick harmonica
has wood right here you got some more
wood for me more wood just for medicals
high-quality people this is actual wood
right here dude I need it too cuz I I
pay less for insurance now cuz I've been
using it cause like
pay hundreds of dollars anymore you need
it I feel much better now thanks okay
I'll just tap on it the whole
technically this is also wood oh it is
really thin what yep thanks a lot you
feel good about yourself yeah well now
he's safe all right
I am pretty safe he's actually he
actually could do some dangerous [ __ ]
right now because of all the good will
he do I've calmed down a lot like I I
think about life like and in consequence
crazy [ __ ] yeah I mean we were to you
you didn't know me when I was younger so
I did stupid stupid things so like now
it's more like if we zipline or whatever
then that's most people's oh I live life
on the wild side right and I'm like oh
yeah that's that he would similar
without the line that's how you do it
that's what you would do no light above
a cliff seemed like that we were riding
or driving and [ __ ] like I would like
hang my hang out side of the car like
outside of the window you know what I
mean like sit outside like this yeah I
got you know I would just hang or
whatever or like if we're in Thailand or
wherever they have these trucks with
bars that are welded and then we just
wanted to like hang outside like monkeys
while the cars driving and then I don't
know all that stuff was fun and I didn't
see it dangerous dude I don't even put
my my hands up on a roller coaster I'm
like no [ __ ] way we're too tall for
that [ __ ] yeah I had to get chopped up
that's what I'm saying I'm scared
do you do it nope cuz I'm like my long
ass or arms I'm like as soon as I see
like the railing or something come close
oh all right I went on a Space Mountain
and I thought about putting my hands up
but I can't see [ __ ] in that so I keep
it right here son
dude I even hunt down face not example
because we're so [ __ ] long I'm just
like oh please don't hit me with
anything cuz I can't see [ __ ] oh yeah
but the arms I do agree I realized
though that I understand fear now
because when we went hiking and rock
climbing we have this friend who's like
this Cambodia monkey and he's here Eliot
yeah cuz he climbs everything
he like does that free no [ __ ] cable
rock climbing [ __ ] [ __ ] and then um you
know I I would I would go on a hike with
him and and look down and I'm like work
this is hiking like we're going through
we're just climbing on rocks and I'm
trembling right and I'm like this is not
that bad but for some reason my mind is
like thinking about insurance and and I
could get hurt my first experience with
the human being that I knew that died
was when I was a kid and in Indiana we
had a babysitter that was our babysitter
and he died rock climbing like with his
dad doing the same [ __ ] like doing that
whole like free ball thing without ropes
what did that teach you
was that to teach you - I live my foots
it fully or all like yep scared live
afraid he'd be risk averse living fear
everything I feel like sad that I'm
scared now
I mean I feel feel safe very much so me
but then I had to go up and down that
wall and then I felt better because I
was like oh I can do it now I'll do the
wall if I'm got ropes and then I found
minute like one of those rock climbing
gyms those are fun cuz when I was in
Hawaii - and then Mariel wanted to do
like this super hike work it's like even
her friend who's like a local Hawaiian
she's like it is frightening for her
like it's windy up there and the road is
like like half the [ __ ] with this
table right and Mary was like well I
wanted to do that stuff but you don't
want to I was like [ __ ] go ahead were
you not listening to me she said it's
very dangerous and there's a really
narrow road did you not heard she's like
well I want to go I was like go ahead BZ
go ahead do your thing good I'll put you
on the beach yeah I don't watch you fall
from that cliff and I'm like oh my god
Jesus you know that like come on I mean
is it the people the pina coladas are
down here off there did you hear did you
hear that she just wants to do that
stuff she thinks I'm holding her back I
was like I'm not holding you back from
anything I just won't do it you could go
with your friends I know her feeling
though cuz that's Patrick I'm like I'm
like oh man we gotta go together or else
it's not fun okay look man baby [ __ ]
Nick you're both like hiking on a
vacation ahaha nothing yeah
I'm sayin man
[Music]
[Music]